Grant. Thanks for coming in, buddy.
I know you don't believe in psychiatrists and that's okay because I'm not a
psychiatrist, so don't worry. Don't get so defensive. Okay.
Put your hands down grant. Cause you know what you've been up to, you know,
you've been acting very strange.
Your friends have been telling me you've been acting different ever since the
pandemic and grant. Let's just, let's just talk about it, right?
It's time for an intervention. Act like a vote.
A.
What's next is insane.
Oh yeah.
You're going to see a whole new side of uncle G
I'm talking crazy
or you ready? Can you handle it?
Will you love me? Will you hate me?
Woo, indeed. Grant.
Now some of your friends think it's just because you're losing a lot of money
during the pandemic now on the rumors of my bankruptcy, that is soon to happen.
Yes, it's true. Okay. I'm losing the plane, the condo,
we all know you're stressed grant and you know,
maybe it's time to like meditate or something,
but you got to stop posting to social media, buddy. I don't need a lecture.
My grown got wrong, man. Oh, it was like he finally speaks. Huh?
Well really you're so grown. Explain that.
[Inaudible].
Yeah, I know I'm speechless to grant, uh,
and that's not even all there is for this next clip.
I'm actually going to be a wearing some safety protection.
This is for my safety, not for yours.
Okay.
Grant, when you see that video of yourself,
do you see a man who is saying Kevin, the next day,
the next day nurse to lose, you can come in, come in here, get in here
and losing brands, patient record grant Cardone.
I was unable to get the patient responsive for the rest of the session.
He would only shout cryptically, have a 10 X day, but with a few more sessions,
I do think that he may make some progress,
but notice that as soon as he left, he did post another tick tock,
which is deeply concerning follow up next week.
[inaudible].